le premier ministre a longuement
expliqué à la mi-journée au cours d'un
point de presse son plan de sécurité
sanitaire et les raisons de celui ci
puis il a dû batailler à l'assemblée
pour répondre à l'opposition qui lui
reprocher une certaine à décision
politique
compte rendu de la journée et des débats
au palais beaumont à philippe boisserie
et christophe vignal pour afficher la
mobilisation de son gouvernement lionel
jospin a sorti la preuve par set
pas moins de sept ministres à ses côtés
lors de sa conférence de presse celui de
l'agriculture
à sa droite celui de la santé relégué en
bout de table avec un credo le
gouvernement agit sans précipitation
mais avec détermination
lorsqu existe un risque potentiel majeur
pour la santé publique
toutes les décisions nécessaires à la
sécurité sanitaire doivent être prises
lionel jospin n'a donc pas attendu
l'avis des experts
après les propos du président de la
république la semaine dernière il savait
que l'opposition l'attendait avec un feu
nourri de questions
le premier ministre avait donc ses
réponses et son ministre de
l'agriculture pour calmer les ardeurs
je voudrais vous mettre en garde contre
cette tentation qui peut être la vôtre
d'une exploitation politique de la
situation
le veut s'est avérée un peu pieux quand
le président de la république a dit
qu'il souhaitait qu'on interdise
totalement les farines animales
on a entendu du côté de la majorité des
voix pour le critiquer sévèrement
et bien aujourd'hui on fait ce qu'il a
demandé on avait donc bien tort de le
critiquer à ce moment là et les
critiques ne s'arrêtait pas là il y
avait aussi ceux qui pensaient que le
premier ministre en faisait trop
le gouvernement jospin pressé de toutes
parts elle prend cette décision
scientifiquement elle ne se justifie pas
il y avait ceux qui auraient bien aimé
qu'il en fasse un peu plus cette
décision est prise maintenant donc on ne
va pas s'en plaindre
je crois qu'il faut aller plus loin on
ne peut pas remplacer la peste par le
choléra et dire que maintenant on va
nourrir les bovins avec du soja
américain qui est viadeo gm lionel
jospin y en a peut-être pas fini avec ce
dossier
mais l'important pour lui était de se
placer dans le camp de l'action plutôt
que de subir et les événements et la
pression de l'elysée et richard le cas
parce qu'il y a